Hey everyone, my name is Will and in
this talk we're going to be learning all
about the knowledge graph mullet and how
it can trim graph rag
complexity. Uh let's jump right in. So
bear with me a little bit in this
analogy. Uh, but if you're famili
familiar with the mullet haircut, this
is a classic business in the front,
party in the back, uh, sort of short up
front, long in the back, uh, hairstyle
that, uh, was popular in the in the 80s
and '90s. And if we think of like what
are the benefits of the mullet haircut,
it's really all about lowmaintenance,
easy to work with, but versatile and
adaptable in different environments.
And if we extend that analogy to
knowledge graphs, that gives us the
knowledge graph mullet, which is all
about property graph in the front and
RDF triples in the back. So really what
this talk is about is combining concepts
from the property graph world and the
RDF world to have a hybrid and versatile
approach for working with knowledge
graphs.
So, if you're familiar with the graph
ecosystem at all, you've probably heard
some of this terminology. But property
graph and RDF are typically thought of
as two totally different paradigms for
working with graphs. Uh, in the property
graph world, we're thinking about nodes,
relationships, key value pair
properties. We're thinking about
traversing the graph using pattern
matching uh often with a query language
called cipher. In the RDF world, we're
typically talking about uh ontologies
using a query language called sparkle,
thinking about triples. Uh RDF comes
from the semantic web and linked data
world.
And what I want to show today is that
really these concepts can be used
together where we can really leverage
the benefits and sort of best of both
worlds uh to again expose a property
graph model for how we want to think
about and query the data but leverage
the scalability of RDF triples uh in our
knowledge graph.
system. We're going to take a look at an
open source project called Dgraph to uh
work with our knowledge graphs. Um let's
talk about really like a working
definition of knowledge graph first of
all. So we're going to say that a
knowledge graph is really just an
instance of a property graph. So the
property graph model is all about nodes.
Nodes can have one or more labels, which
is a way to uh tell us what type of node
uh we're talking about, a way to group
nodes. You can think of labels as kind
of similar to like tables from the
relational database world. Uh and then
we have relationships that have a single
type and direction. Then we can store
arbitrary key value pair properties on
nodes and
relationships and the the semantics
right so how our entities are connected
is encoded in the data model we don't
just say that two nodes are related to
each other we say that this talk has a
certain topic or this talk was presented
at a conference ments, right? We're
talking about things, not strings, which
was the the title of Google's blog post
in 2012 introducing the Google knowledge
graph. But I think that's I think that's
right. I think that's one of the most
important pieces of thinking about
knowledge graphs is that we have a
canonical representation of the thing.
Dgraph was first open sourced and
released in
2017 and uh initially
was really optimizing for large scale
graph data. So the the D is for
distributed and scale in terms of
volume. Uh so the original Dgraph team
came from uh expols from Google that
were inspired by uh Google's spanner
graph. Dgraph is this really interesting
sort of hybrid in this world of graph
databases where we use the property
graph model for uh data modeling and
querying uh but we use RDF uh for data
interchange and we work with triples as
the smallest unit of record. So if we
take a look at these two paradigms that
we're talking about the property graph
model uh where nodes node labels
relationship types and key value pair
properties are sort of the the core
fundamentals of the data model and if we
compare that with RDF which is all about
triples. So subject predicate object
which we can think of as like a
sentence. Uh the subject this is always
going to be a node. A predicate can be a
relationship or a property. And then an
object in the case where uh the
predicate is a relationship is a node or
the value of a property.
Let's look at how Dgraph works with both
property graphs and triples. So the
first thing we need to do to model a
property graph as an RDF triple is to
have a unique ID for each node. The
unique ID maps to some offset in disk so
that we're able to traverse the graph
very quickly and efficiently.
Then the next piece is again to
uh think of our node as the value of our
unique ID. So the subject we said is
always going to be a node and uh really
specifically it's always going to be a
unique ID. That's like a pointer to the
node. Then the predicate is going to be
uh a relationship or a property. And in
the case where it's
a relationship then our object is going
to be another uh node ID. So this is
going to be a predicate that connects
two nodes as a relationship or it's
going to be the value of our property.
Dgraph uses an important optimization
called a posting list where we are uh
grouping by predicate and uh using a
list of
the unique node ids of all the nodes
that this node is connected to by that
predicate. So this allows us to traverse
the graph uh very efficiently.
DQL we said is the query language that
we use with Dgraph. Uh DQL was very much
inspired by GraphQL. GraphQL was uh open
sourced by Facebook shortly uh before
Dgraph uh was released and uh at that
time there's a lot of interest in uh
exploring GraphQL beyond its intention
as an API query language. So we can see
some similar concepts from DQL.
uh we start every DQL graph traversal
with a well- definfined starting point.
So that's our root criteria here where
we're often using an index to find the
nodes as the starting point for our
traversal. Then we use a selection set
structure which is this nested structure
that uh specifies both the properties
that we want to return to our query uh
but also this nested structure
represents a traversal in the
graph. Similar to GraphQL the data
returned from a DQL query is JSON that
matches the structure of our selection
set. Let's take a look at an example uh
using news data. Uh so how would we
create a knowledge graph of news
articles? So here's an example from the
New York Times. Uh so we have uh a news
article and if we think of what sort of
graph model we would build from this,
well we think of the uh entities that
are mentioned like what are the
organizations, the uh people, the topics
that are mentioned. we might model those
as nodes in the graph. We also have uh
the author. We have images to think of
and we also have unstructured data to
work with in the graph. Now there are
different approaches for how we might
chunk and embed unstructured data uh
maybe using the semantic structure of
the article. In this example, we're just
going to say every paragraph is a chunk.
uh and we're going to model those chunks
as nodes in the
graph. So here's a graph model uh that
we're going to use to represent our news
knowledge graph. We have an article node
that represents the article itself. you
h it has a a URL, a publish date, a
title, an abstract, but then we have uh
the author of the article, topics that
may be mentioned in the article,
organizations that may be mentioned. Uh
we also have geographic areas that might
be mentioned in the article, uh and
images, uh as well. So you can see how
we can traverse from the article to the
topic node to then other articles that
have the same topic or that mention the
same geographic
location. Now we mentioned uh chunking
and embedding earlier. Uh what we're
going to do is calculate an embedding of
each chunk and store that as a node
property. This will allow us to use
vector search as an entry point for our
graph. So, uh, vector similarity search
gives us an entry point into the graph.
We can think of this as the lexical
graph where we're identifying chunks of
a document that are uh, close to vector
space
uh, of a embedding of our query. But
that's just the start in graph rag. Uh
in a naive rag approach, we would do the
vector search to find these chunks. That
document would then be injected into the
prompt to add uh context. But in graph
rag, that's just the starting point.
Then we traverse through the graph to
the article nodes to the topics that are
relevant for this article to other
articles that have the same topic or
that mention the same
organization. Um, and again that's just
one entry point. The uh other entry
points might be using a geospatial
index. Maybe we want to find all of the
uh news about uh areas within a certain
region or find news articles uh near me
and then traverse the graph to find
other relevant articles that become
context for uh for our model. Similarly,
we might have uh an image embedding
model where we're doing uh image
similarity search as well. again just as
an entry point. So I like to think of
graph rag really being all about
different subgraph entry points where we
have this concept of the lexical graph
for vector search with unstructured
data. Uh the domain graph that we're
sort of traversing through to find
relevant context for the
model. Let's take a look at uh a
hands-on example of actually using this
data uh with Dgraph. This is a tool
called Rattell which is a query
workbench for Dgraph. Uh we can execute
DQL queries and work with and visualize
the results. Our initial query was just
a simple count of the number of
articles. Let's look at a more complex
query uh where we are searching for the
first 10 articles then traversing the
graph to find topics connected to those
articles. So we can uh inspect the graph
in this graph visualization to have an
idea of how these topics are connected
to articles. Let's look at a more
complex example. Uh so here we are
filtering for articles that are
published after a certain date and then
traversing to the geographic areas
mentioned in those articles.
Let's see how we can use the
uh geographic distance search in Dgraph.
So here we're looking for geographic
areas in the news that are within 50
kilometers of New York City and then
traversing to find the articles
connected to those geographic regions.
And we can see things like Manhattan and
Brooklyn. Uh let's look at a vector
search example. So using the uh vector
similarity search functionality in
Dgraph, we're passing a embedding uh I
think this is an embedding of the phrase
moneyaundering and looking for articles
that are close in vector space and then
traversing to find uh topics, geographic
regions, organizations connected to
these uh these articles.
We can then add a more complex traversal
to then search from those articles that
were a match for our vector similarity
search to traverse through the topic
nodes to find other articles that have
overlapping topics but that may not have
shown up through our vector similarity
search. And this gives us uh a way to in
this case visually explore uh the graph.
But of course we can look at the JSON
representation uh of the data returned
that matches our selection set. Okay,
that was a quick look at using DQL to
query our Dgraph instance. Um I want to
talk about some of the features in the
latest release of Dgraph. Uh the first
interesting bit is that uh all of the
enterprise features of Dgraph have been
moved into a single open-source release.
Uh and we were continuing to add new
features. Uh the interesting one I want
to dive into in this case is model
context protocol. So the MCP server for
Dgraph. Uh so let's talk a little bit
about MCP and then we'll look
specifically at the Dgraph MCP server.
Uh so this is a screenshot from the
anthropic deep learning.ai course uh
which is linked here. This is um I think
a really good course if you're
interested in not just learning about
the concepts of MCP but how do you
actually build and deploy MCP servers?
Fundamentally, MCP is a way of exposing
tools to models. And in the context of
databases, this means we're giving uh
the database uh we're giving the model
rather a way to interact with our
database. With Dgraph, uh each Dgraph
instance serves a MCP server. There's a
uh readonly instance which will only
expose uh the ability to execute queries
or inspect the schema. Uh and then the
full endpoint also exposes functionality
for mutations. So adding data and also
tool for altering the
schema. So some of the use cases for the
Dgraph MCP server are in agentic coding
assistant uh environments. So tools like
windsurf or cursor uh where we're able
to do things like leveraging the schema
or the data that are retrieved to the
MCP server to um autogenerate writing uh
CRUD endpoints in our app or other way
generating uh DQL queries in our app.
Another use case might be more
exploratory data analysis uh which we
might do in a tool like cloud desktop
where we're actually generating DQL
queries uh
and fetching data from the database to
understand uh what data is in our
graph. Let's take a look at using the
Dgraph MCP server uh with cloud desktop.
So the first thing I'm going to do is
sign in to uh hyper mode and create a
new graph. Hyper mode graphs are uh
powered by Dgraph. So this is going to
deploy a Dgraph cluster including the
MCP server endpoint. So we can see the
MCP configuration uh in addition to the
Dgraph connection string. So we'll copy
the MCP
configuration and in cloud desktop we'll
edit the developer config and paste in
that MCP configuration. Uh and then
restart cloud which will give us access
to the MCP server tools for Dgraph. Uh
let's load some sample data into Dgraph.
So let's uh create fictitious customer
product and order data for say uh for an
e-commerce use
case. And so the first thing that Claude
is going to do is update the schema uh I
should say actually the first thing it's
going to do is inspect the schema uh and
see that our database is empty. Then
generate a graph schema that represents
the data model that we're going to work
with. So orders and how they're
connected to products and customers. Uh
then Claude is going to generate a
series of mutations to actually create
data in the graph generating uh
fictitious customer names, customer
information,
uh products and so on. Now, it's
important to to point out here that with
database MCP servers, it's the model
that is generating the database query
and then using the tools defined in the
MCP server to execute those queries
against the database and claude is smart
enough to verify that the data created
in the database matches its
expectations. So here we can see uh that
claude is generating DQL queries to
verify uh the data was actually created
uh as
expected. Uh in this case it found
missing relationships uh and so it's
adding a mutation to add those
relationships to the graph. Now this is
a really interesting way for learning
new developer tooling. So here we've uh
created uh a graph schema. We've added
data to the graph without really having
to uh to worry about the specific query
language. But it's a great way to learn
that query language, learn how to use
these developer tools. Uh now let's
generate a graph visualization to
understand the data in the graph. So
here Claude generates a query to fetch
data from the graph and generates the
JavaScript to render a graph
visualization. Um so this is a helpful
way to understand the connections in our
graph. Uh and we have ways for viewing
the schema uh zeroing in on customers
and orders or just inspecting uh product
information. We have different layout
options in addition to the typical
forced directed layout. Uh hierarchical
or radial layouts can be useful for
interpreting graphs. Um but let's stick
with the forced directed layout and
let's explore using Dgraph for
generating product recommendations for a
specific user. So this is a a typical
graph database use case uh generating
personalized recommendations by
traversing the graph. Uh you can think
of the different approaches we could
take here from collaborative filtering
uh which could be find similar users in
the graph. What are those users
purchasing that uh our user is not?
those may be good items to recommend to
the user to content based
recommendations based on the purchase
history of our user. Uh what are
attributes that they may be interested
in uh demographic approaches as well.
And here Claude is generating uh queries
that show us using these different
approaches uh and then how these can be
combined to generate a single database
query. Now Claude doesn't always get the
the queries right. So this example uh we
can see there's an error with the first
approach and so Claude is going to
iterate a bit uh until we get back
results as
expected. Again really useful tool I
think for understanding some of these
concepts. Uh now our final deliverable
here is going to be a HTML report that
Claude is going to generate that allows
us to explore the different approaches
for implementing these uh
recommendations and show us the results
as well as the DQL query used for each
of these. So that was a look at the
Dgraph MCP server. If we zoom out a
little bit, so far we've seen how to
work with knowledge graphs, uh how to
expose tools to a model for interacting
with that knowledge graph uh through
Dgraph. Uh but there's a piece that's
missing here which is the agent
orchestration. Uh and so to enable
building uh agentic
apps at hyper mode, we've created the
modus agent orchestration framework
which is an open- source framework for
creating AI agents uh really for
bringing data to models and exposing
tools uh and abstractions for working uh
with agentic flows. So modus is an open
source project. Uh you can find this on
GitHub. Really the functionality we
think of uh in modus is abstractions not
only for working with models and data
but a runtime for uh working with
largecale number of agents that are
stateful and longunning. uh which is why
we think it's important to have a
runtime uh as well as an SDK library for
working with agents. Modus does some
interesting things with web assembly. So
we use web assembly to target multiple
languages uh for different SDKs. So
you're able to write your logic in
languages like go or assembly script and
then under the hood that is compiled to
web assembly and a single unified
graphqle API is generated that leverages
uh the types that you've defined in your
modus app and the signature uh of the
functions you've defined to stitch a
single graphql schema uh together. Uh
the modus runtime uh leveraging web
assembly gives us some advantages as
well for security and a sandbox
environment for your AI agent to run in.
Uh but all of that web assembly aspect
is abstracted away from uh from the
user. So leveraging now these open
source components. So the mo modus
orchestration
uh framework leveraging dgraph for
building knowledge graphs. Uh let's take
a look
at building domain specific agents
starting with a prompt. Uh so this is uh
the core for hyper mode agents where we
think it's really important to be able
uh to get up and running with a domain
specific agent by writing a prompt and
exposing tools via MCP server. Uh so uh
for my final demo, we'll take uh a quick
look at uh hyper mode agents.
I'm going to switch back to hyper mode
and we're going to go to the threads tab
uh which is our uh area for building
agents. Uh let's create a new agent.
We'll give him a name blah blah blah
works in our marketing department as a
social media intern. Uh we're going to
define a prompt which gives our agent a
bit of background. He's going to be a
social media expert uh who's really good
at uh creating short snippets that are
showing developers how to use uh deep
technical tooling and explain technical
concepts. Uh we'll choose a reasoning
model. Uh we'll use the GPT41
uh model to orchestrate this agent. Uh
and the next thing we need to do is add
connections. So our agent needs to be
able to uh interact with its
environment. So we'll give him access to
GitHub, Notion uh and our company docs
through ref. These are all MCP servers
that are uh exposing tools that uh allow
the agent to interact uh with those
services uh and authorized uh our
behalf. So let's give him a task to
analyze a specific GitHub repo. In this
case, the Hypernews repo, which has uh
the tooling for importing, building,
quering, and working with that news
knowledge graph that uh I showed
earlier. And we're going to generate uh
social media posts that explain how to
use some of the concepts explained in
that GitHub repo. So at the beginning we
can see the tool calls that our agent
made. So first he's searching for the
Hyperne GitHub repo using uh tools from
the GitHub MCP server. then getting uh
specific file contents to use uh to
generate social media posts uh that show
how to use specific features uh
explained in uh or I should say
implemented in this GitHub repo. So this
is a good start. Um but let's ask our
agent to update these posts to include
some relevant code snippets.
Uh, and so our agent is now going
to choose uh what tools to call here.
Uh, going back to GitHub, looking at uh,
source files that may be relevant and
adding code snippets here. So now you
can see our social media posts have uh,
code snippets where appropriate. And
this is a mix of DQL queries when we're
talking about Dgraph, some Go code from
uh the modus SDK, some terminal
commands. Uh this looks good. Uh let's
ask our agent to save this to our uh
notion workspace so that we can cue
these up uh to post on uh our Twitter
account.
And uh we need to tell our agent uh what
page uh to use. So we'll say uh let's
post these to my private
scratchpad. And again, we've authorized
uh the agent to have access to our
notion workspace through the notion MCP
server. Uh so that's how our agent is
able to access my scratchpad page. Uh,
and we can see the notion tools that our
agent used to update our notion page.
And we switch over to notion, we can see
my scratch pad that includes our updated
code snippets for our social media
posts. So, that's really cool. We uh
built an agent just from a prompt, gave
him access to actually interact with
GitHub and notion uh on my behalf. One
thing that's really neat uh about hyper
mode agents is I can now eject to code
uh to have the modus code that uh we're
using to actually run this agent. So I
can then add more complex logic, other
connections uh to enhance my agent using
modus. So, that was a quick look at
hyper mode agents, being able to create
an agent from a prompt and access to MCP
powered connections
uh while also being able to eject to
code leveraging uh our open-source
tooling. Hypermote agents is in early
access now. Uh so there's a link there
on the screen if you'd like to uh sign
up to give this a try for early
access. Great. Well, that was a look at
the knowledge graph mullet uh how we can
leverage tools from the property graph
and RDF ecosystems
uh to build powerful graph rag workflows
as the foundation for building AI
agents. Uh I hope you found that useful.
Uh feel free to uh use that link on the
screen to check out the slides and also
look at the resources uh that we've
added in the video description. Uh
thanks a lot for watching. Cheers.